[Musique]
grasset il n'a pas d'aidé
figaro live il est 9h nous sommes en
direct ce matin 9 heures en france mais
10 heures à moscou c'est là que nous
nous avons 11 heures à moscou pardon
fabrice vous ai bien fait de me
reprendre fabrice naudé langlois qui se
présentent tout seul du coup du figaro
économie et qui a été correspondant pour
le figaro à moscou pendant plusieurs
années bon jean fabrice merci d'être
avec moi alors on explique défilé
militaire qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui alors c'est la
grande parade de pour célébrer la
victoire de la grande guerre patriotique
comme on dit en russie comme on disait à
l'époque soviétique donc célébrer la
victoire de 1945 seconde guerre mondiale
sur le nazisme voilà mais qui a toujours
été appelé la grande guerre patriotique
depuis staline et donc c'est par
définition un défilé militaire quel que
soit le pays c'est une démonstration de
force évidemment aujourd'hui en 2022 aux
3 dans le troisième mois de la guerre en
ukraine ce démon des monstration de
force a une signification toute
particulière avec beaucoup de questions
qui se posent sur ce que vladimir
poutine que l'on voit à l'image dans la
tribune pourrait dire dans quelques
instants oui on suivra évidemment tout
ça c'est très symbolique vous l'avais
dit au vu du contexte en ukraine alors
justement fabrice pourquoi le le 9 mai
nous fait c'est lui même alors c'est en
fait c'est une simple question de
décalage horaire il y a eu entre en 1945
une première édition signée à reims le 7
mai 45 qui prévoyait l'arrêt des combats
ne lui met d'accord les soviétiques qui
était à berlin qui sont arrivés les
premiers à berlin souhaitaient avoir
leur propre acte de reddition il a été
signé le 8 mai 45 à 23 heures heure de
berlin 23 heures heure de berlin c'était
une heure du matin le 9 mai décalage
horaire de dix heures qui évidemment
guère voilà il est là le 9 mai
à moscou et donc staline a conservé
cette date on peut imaginer qu'il a
voulu distinguer toujours cette date
parce que dans le contexte de guerre
froide il n'était pas question de
célébrer cette victoire en même temps
que les alliés avec l'intention qui a
prévalu au cours de quarante ans de
guerre froide vous réagissez évidemment
sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube sur twitch
je lis toutes vos questions vos
remarques je les transmets à fabrice on
essaye d'y répondre on a besoin de bien
comprendre l'importance de cette journée
c'est l'équivalent du 14 juillet pour
les français alors d'une certaine
manière oui il y a eu après l'époque
soviétique
une fête nationale qui a été instauré
alors de mémoire je n'ai pas vérifié me
semble que c'est le 12 juin mais elle
n'a jamais revêtu une importance de ce 9
mai donc les marques et surtout pas par
ce défilé militaire est alors pour vous
pour étayer ce que vous dites j'ai lu ce
matin qu'il y avait un sondage en russie
69 % de la population considère que
c'est le jour férié le plus important en
russie incontestablement avec donc comme
point d'orgue cette parade militaire qui
en général très spectaculaire avec des
des dizaines de milliers de soldats qui
défilent sur la place rouge donc un
écrin extraordinaire ou souvenait qu'à
l'époque soviétique
il y avait toujours vouvoyé les
officiels sur la sur la tribune
officielle à côté du même sur le
mausolée de lénine alors pendant de
nombreuses années sur la place rouge
n'était pas autorisé le public c'est
vraiment que les invités l'élite du
régime des anciens combattants qu'il en
reste
le public était relégué en général en
dehors de la place rouge où les
véhicules défilent et convergeaient mais
il n'y avait pas en tout cas de ces
dernières années de défilés pour le
public dans les rues d'après ce que nous
écrivaient ce matin notre correspondant
à moscou elle un bar lui et je voulais
savoir l'article nous y aura des
kilomètres excellent au filet ont dans
les rues qui convergent vers la place
rouge donc le public de moscou pourra
pour assister au défilé évidemment la
population regarde le défilé à la
télévision alors je réponds quand même
sur youtube a inc hic et nunc qui nous
dit pourquoi diffuser se décider c'est
vrai que d'habitude on diffuse pas se
défiler on a les images après mais c'est
vrai que cette fois il y a une
un
événement tout particulier avec cette
guerre en ukraine et on attend notamment
ce que dira vladimir poutine c'est pour
ça qu'on suit particulièrement ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui à moscou il ya ce
défilé militaire fabrice mais il ya
aussi un défilé populaire après avec des
gens qui marchent avec un des photos de
leurs ancêtres qui ont fait la guerre ça
c'est important pour vladimir poutine
oui et ça de mémoire ça n'a pas eu lieu
chaque année ou alors c'était juste
quelques personnes qui brandissaient
effectivement les les portraits de héros
de la grande guerre patriotique de la
seconde guerre mondiale ça s'appelle le
régiment immortel oui et auquel
participent auquel a participé parlant
que les quelques années jean luc
mélenchon auquel participent parfois
vladimir poutine ça c'est important
d'avoir le peuple avec lui bien sûr on
est il faut plus que jamais on est dans
une guerre de l'information et l'admiré
lenski hier à fait aussi de la
communication de participer à la guerre
de l'information pour montrer qu'il
était soutenu par les pays du g7 par
l'occident pour dire que cette guerre
2022 résonne avec la guerre de 1945 et
on est dans une situation paradoxale où
chaque camp l'ukraine d'un côté la
russie de l'autre affirme être
finalement de nouveau en guerre contre
des nazis puisque bien servir ce qu'ils
assimilent le régime de poutine année
nazis avec les exactions qui ont été
commises et depuis le début de cette
guerre le 24 février vladimir poutine
dit qu'il est là pour des nazifié
l'ukraine encore en début de week-end
l'admirent poutine a dit le militaire se
battent coude à coude pour la libération
de leur terre natale de la crasse les
nazis on peut s'attendre à ce qu'ils
donnent
réitère ce genre de propos aujourd'hui
vous voyez ces images en direct ces
images je le précise fournie par la
télévision russe un contrôle guerre de
l'information vous le disiez et fabrice
c'est très important de préciser que ce
sont des images par la russie justement
ce comparatif ce comparatif fabrice
entre ce qu'il s'est passé pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale la grande guerre
patriotique et ce qui se passe
maintenant alors qu'on voit c'est le
général challe goût ainsi l'image
générale c'est le ministre denis sans
chaillou absolument qui est ici
cette comparaison entre
1945 et aujourd'hui ils insistent dessus
vladimir poutine alors il faut rappeler
aussi le caractère unique kaka le
souvenir de la seconde guerre mondiale
en russie
en union soviétique il ya quand même un
bilan absolument terrifiant et le bilan
le plus lourd humainement de la seconde
guerre mondiale selon les chiffes selon
les estimations on dit que c'est 20 24
28 millions de morts en union soviétique
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale c'est
l'union soviétique qui a payé le plus
lourd tribut humain on parle d'une
dizaine de millions de soldats tués et
au moins d'une quinzaine de millions de
civils donc vraiment l' union soviétique
a payé le prix du sang et puis il faut
pas oublier qu'il ya cette parade a
toujours eu une importance du point de
vue communication pour staline parce que
elle visait aussi à effacer le péché je
dirais du pacte molotov-ribbentrop le
pacte germano-soviétique de 1939 où
staline s'est allié à hitler ne faut pas
l'oublier et après l'invasion nazie de
la l'union soviétique en 1941 staline
bascule donc par la force des choses
dans le camp sous préfet je voudrais
qu'on écoute un mouvement parlais tout à
l'heure avec sergueï choïgou le ministre
de la défense exprime vous me direz
après ce qu'il a dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
pourtant clamé en choeur par les troupes
c'est toujours extrêmement spectaculaire
mais gêné j'ai eu la chance d'assister
deux années de suite mais il ya une
douzaine d'années cela à cette parade du
9 mai quand vous avez en face de vous
ces milliers d'hommes qui clame ce cri
de gloire ou rares comme comme chez nous
mais vraiment rancoeur c'est extrêmement
respecté cette image avec sergueï
choïgou qui a disparu un certain temps 1
c'est intéressant de le voir ça aussi
c'est un message de la lumière poutine
les hommes qui m'entourent sont toujours
là sont toujours autour de moi alors on
se croirait un petit peu revenu à
l'époque soviétique ou la parade du 9
mai est l occasion de conté qui était la
tribune est ce que tel membre du
politburo avait disparu était encore
vivant puisque évidemment une opacité
totale régnait on en est revenu un peu à
ce genre de spéculation avec le régime
de poutine et vivement sergueï choïgou
qui est un des plus proches
collaborateurs collaborateurs d'hommes
de poutine a effectivement disparu des
écrans pendant quelques semaines
devraient toutes sortes de spéculations
ont été développés sont personnellement
je sois capable de vous apporter la
grande île a parlé en accapare n'a parlé
des ennuis de santé mais vous savez
qu'en ce moment fantasme beaucoup sur
les ennuis santé potentiel de vladimir
poutine lui-même toutes sortes de
rumeurs circulent c'est très prudent au
sujet des rumeurs donc on circulait à
l'encontre de
sergueï choïgou on a dit et ce qu'il
aura été
puni sanctionné parce que la victoire
n'avait pas été assez rapide en
l'ukraine toutes sortes de spéculations
ont circulé cette jambe intérêt aussi à
faire sa crise et ces rumeurs donc faut
être extrêmement prudent toujours est il
qu'aujourd'hui il est au premier rang
présent pour conduire l'armée je salue
tous ceux qui nous rejoignent sur
youtube sur le figaro sur twitch on suit
ce défilé du 9 mai depuis a pas ce goût
de moscou depuis moscou au delà des
images fabrice qu'est ce qu'on peut
attendre de vladimir poutine il va
prendre la parole tout est possible
voilà ce que j'allais dire parce que
encore une fois nié toutes sortes de
spéculations de rumeurs on a dit
peut-être qu'il va
déclarer officiellement la guerre à
l'ukraine puisque jusqu'à présent la
russie officiellement n'est pas en
guerre mais en opération militaire
spéciale os avec le mot guerre est
proscrit dans les médias russes
le porte parole du kremlin du non a
priori ça ce sont les bêtises on a parlé
de de mobilisation générale qui serait
décrétée là aussi le porte parole du
classement général qu'est ce que ça
voudrait dire que ça voudrait dire les
jeunes gens à partir pharisiens et oui
s'il ya une mobilisation générale mais
effectivement ça ne devrait pas la
langue le porte parole du kremlin a
démenti
vladimir enfin on disait aussi que
vladimir poutine aurait souhaité
annoncer une victoire décisive dans ce
style c'est possible quelle victoire
annoncée au jardin du mail potter alors
demande parlons d'après les dernières
informations les derniers résistants
dans la fameuse usine sidérurgique
géante azoff talent à marie-paule
quelques centaines peut-être de fonds
datant sont toujours en train d'opposer
une résistance farouche dans ce
labyrinthe de béton et d'acier
est ce qu'il y aurait pu y avoir une
annonce dans la journée d enseigner
marioupol est entièrement tombée
évidemment les résistants aux ukrainiens
vont faire absolument tout pour déjouer
ce pronostic donc difficile de spéculer
sur quelque elle annonce pourrait
pourrait faire vladimir poutine si ce
n'est galvaniser son peuple montré que
que toute la russie et derrière lui dans
ce qu'il appelle la libération de
l'ukraine je vous propose qu'on écoute
ce qui se passe un peu d'ambiance à
moscou avec ça y est chaude ou le
ministre de la défense qui passe en
revue les différents corps de l'armée et
ses hourra hourra des militaires en
écoute
[Musique]
dans la région des grands lacs amende
aussi rejoindre les messieurs voici ce
que tu dirais oui ce qu'un masque au
coeur des zones on a deux gâteaux
beignets salamone numéro
[Musique]
le défilé était prêt et manifestement
vladimir poutine à prendre la parole il
s'approche d'une micro oui il prend la
parole très tôt à 9h15 alors dans les
habitudes de ce défi des rois langues
j'avais des filets sans forcément
toujours des prises de paroles
significative alors ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on écoute vladimir
poutine qui va s'exprimer en russe
évidemment fabrice écoutent ils essayent
de traduire parce que sa femme avait dit
votre triste mais pas fabrice parle très
bien le russe et puis on essaie de faire
des petits points sur ce que dit
vladimir poutine c'est très important
matros
urgente et it tard chine nietzsche menin
et ypres apprécié
d'avoir échoué à fixer ray général est
admirable
pas grave les oies cygnes hommes veliki
palier des
êtres ordinaires
ceux
qui me
suivent attaques ont d'abord à jean paul
billig dragon mask wheeling radoi chivu
minsk stalingrad xe qu'on soit au plan
tactique chez vous éteignez votre trajet
et east and africa novembre c'est
bizarre parce nous marcherons lyonnais
récidivait
sur quatre a good night in
maschera higgins va ça y est ce que roda
niveau sur neuf tirs et 12 fourni mouche
bisping europe pour duke à la frontière
yvetot
bocage
mais ce récit
n'était ni mercredi ni ce que tu es mon
poteau qui n'avait pas encore nous qui
prenons
hiroshima tenace mitran mais garder
la ligne in hd rennais
s'accrochent aux
nations
unies mais blizzard prenez pas la
traduction évidemment mais on vous l'a
fait je suis fabrice les premiers
éléments de l'avenir poutine n'a pour
l'instant il parle de seconde il invoque
il a cité la plupart des grandes
batailles de la seconde guerre mondiale
donc la grande guerre patriotique selon
la terminologie soviétiques et russes
vient évoquer la grande bataille de
koursk
borodino il faut se souvenir que le
laghman est le régime nazi et pénétrer
quand même très profondément dans la
terre soviétique jusqu'à jusqu'à 10mo
portes du caucase jusqu'à la mer noire
dans l'ukraine actuelle bien sûr est que
encore une fois je vous disais alors
plus de 20 millions de morts 24 28
millions selon les estimations
au cours de la semaine mondiale en union
soviétique
on a aperçu d'une image oui l'image un
homme barbu avec un une coiffe blanche
c'est kirill le patriarche de l'église
orthodoxe
depuis depuis la fin de l'union
soviétique
le chef de l'église orthodoxe toujours
dans la tribune officielle vous savez
que c'est un soutien absolument
indéfectible au régime que
vladimir poutine ne défend les valeurs
de l'église orthodoxe et que d'ailleurs
depuis le début de la guerre il ya une
vraie scission entre les ligues majeures
ducks en ukraine il y avait à la fois
une église orthodoxe autocéphale
indépendante mais il y avait toujours
des églises qui dépendaient du
patriarcat de moscou et la plupart
d'entre elles ont dénoncé la guerre mais
on dit qu'elle ne voulait plus dépendre
du patriarcat de moscou on écoute un
nouveau vladimir poutine fabrice traduit
dans quelques instants on revient pour
tout vous expliquer vladimir poutine
souvenirs samos taille est une estrade
soyons justes à dominique
paillé inscription
au niger et imsa monitor qui laisse dire
non il faillit se délient top 14 pro d2
ni tunisie michel pacaux
nommé droguest renée rashid ogooué aract
minicar damiatte cas j'aime c'est atlus
vie ordinaire au titre get smart cities
abri qui offrira à tout âge et n'y
calcium d'abord à ma culture
à nos employés de pichichi
minutes
qui s'exprime depuis la place rouge pour
ce défilé militaire du 9 mai fabrice il
a commencé à parler de l'ukraine il a
expliqué que c'était la seule solution
possible intervention win il n'a pas
attendu longtemps après avoir fait
référence à un sacrifice de la seconde
guerre mondiale y a pas attendu
longtemps pour parler du conflit actuel
en le justifiant en disant que
il y avait une menace de l'otan et que
dit le l'occident et qui est en train de
se préparer
en valeur notre terre mais elle retourne
totalement l'argument c'est pas nouveau
ça fait deux mois qu'ils qui tient cette
rhétorique mais évidemment c'est très
fort qu'il le dise aujourd'hui 9 mai sur
la place rouge est donc selon lui
face aux menaces de l'occident il n'y
avait pas d'autre choix que d'intervenir
donc non seulement pour l'enterrer
l'ukraine 2-2 les nazis qui la
gouvernent c'est l'ensemble du marketing
mais même pour défendre la russie 7
cette menace qu'il ne l'est pas
forcément très clairement avec pas
forcément les mots précis de l'armé
nucléaire ce qu'il peut encore
aujourd'hui s'en servir bien sûr il faut
s'y attendre il va s'en servir il va là
montrer puisque traditionnellement
durant ce défilé une fois que vous avez
des l'infanterie qui défilent vous avez
toutes sortes d'engins de blindés qui
défilent y compris des porteurs de
missiles des justes à moyenne portée
jusqu'à des missiles transcontinentaux
un engin absolument énorme qu'il se
verra je ne sais pas quelle heure selon
elle est motorisée commencera donc ce
sera vraiment la démonstration de force
fait physique joindre les actes
on écoute à nouveau vladimir poutine on
revient et on vous explique ce qui est
en train de dire le président russe
on assiste même
état
palestinien
m
roger meï teï riches
guy wilks h devant la salle d'accueil
affiche
guadeloupe siècle à ce
niveau ce parti mais outre la rade ne
risque
rien n'a rien ap gestionnaire ganisation
réduction jeu devra conjuguer xav au
détail ici mais pas moins chiant à ce
bruit au patriarche co ak voilà vladimir
poutine qui reprend la parole après une
minute de silence en hommage à toutes
les forces russes tous les militaires
tous les hommes femmes russes morts au
combat en 1945 et plus tard oui il a
fait une allusion appuyée sur un épisode
qu'on a peut-être un peu oublié ici en
france qui est au début de la guerre du
dombass guerre d'ukraine en 2014 14
parce qu'il faut pas oublier que cette
guerre a commencé en 2014 avec la
séparation d'une partie du nom basse et
l'annexion de la crimée il ya un épisode
qui était survenue à odessa donc en 2014
où plusieurs dizaines de
personnes ou russes ont péri alors de
mémoire dont il me semble dans l'assaut
l'explosion d'un bâtiment un épisode pas
extrêmement clair et un manuel beaucoup
de propagande d'une part et d'autre
autour de cet épisode est en tout cas
vladimir poutine a fait allusion rendre
hommage aux victimes de cet épisode aux
dessins ou des sacs est une ville
stratégique
oui le port d'odessa connais ça
n'arrive pas à atteindre finalement
voilà ce qu'il n'arrive pas à faire
sauter les verrous précédent qui résiste
toujours mais tous les ingrédients pour
l'instant protégé notamment par nicolas
yves à une centaine de kilomètres
impétueux ou ne resterait qu'un fleuve a
traversé le bouge orientale qui ne peut
être traverser que par cette ville de
nicolas yves est temps que les russes
n'arrive pas à faire sauter le verrou de
cette ville ils ne peuvent pas atteindre
l' ultra stratégiques port d'odessa en
écoute à nouveau ce que dit vladimir
poutine et puis on revient pour analyser
tout ça si dire des radios des
limousines chics d'abris
et de l'ena et na li nina sky schisme
doit
nadio genest apport à vis à vis chez mr
et s'y
tient qu'aux proches au maximum
goodwillie kichenin cazals et mon
premier drive mme naciri bennani
et
mexique d'abord amené à gagner
soir nationaux blaise navarro jeune
homme s'il se refuse à pabbi ados ou là
[Musique]
voilà le pourra très impressionnant sur
la patrie
maintenant
par amel constant que fait vladimir
poutine entre la guerre la grande guerre
patriotique la seconde guerre mondiale
et ce conflit en ukraine oui alors un
discours finalement assez court on n'est
pas dans des discours diminue toujours
très long de manuel macro ont par
exemple finalement pas des annonces
majeures comme certains
pourrait spéculer mais
pas d'annoncé de guerre et pad annonces
de victoire il est plutôt dans la
prospection nous gagnerons nous
vaincrons comme nous avons vaincu en
1945 mais pas nous avons gagné un
parallèle effectivement permanent aller
retour permanent entre
victoire grande guerre patriotique 2,45
et la guerre actuelle il guerre
qui n'est toujours pas officiellement
une guerre bien sûr mais il a quand même
par exemple
fait un appel aux familles et enfin
signe adressé un signe aux familles des
militaires en disant que les familles
des militaires blessés voire décédées
seraient aidés dont il avait déjà dit
mais là il a dit que dans toute la
nation dans le monde entier à la télé ce
qui est toujours paradoxal on est dans
une opération spéciale on ne communique
évidemment absolument pas ou très très
peu sur les victimes russes
mais on aidera bien sûr les familles
donc toujours un petit peu d'ambiguïté
voilà ce discours de vladimir poutine
cours pad annonce
très importante visiblement plutôt un
discours à sa nation à son peuple il y a
eu la revue des troupes par sergueï
choïgou le ministre de la défense c'est
peut-être le moment le plus intéressant
pour l'instant il était bien présent et
c'est lui qui a passé les troupes en
revue des tout à l'heure alors qu'il
avait disparu pendant plusieurs semaines
le défilé militaire va commencer est ce
que il c'est une sorte de défaite grand
ratage pour la dîmière poutine j'entends
par dont fabrice depuis plusieurs
semaines tous les spécialistes me dire
le 9 mai c'est très important finalement
c'est un 9 mai presque comme le nom mais
il n'y a pas de victoire décisive à
offrir un clairement
marioupol n'est pas complètement tomber
même si
il n'ya plus que cette poche de
résistance
dans la fameuse vinh asos talent les
russes ont dit que ma rue paul
était entre leurs mains ce qui fait
actuellement quasiment vrai mais il n'y
a pas eu de grandes victoires l'ensemble
du don de basse n'est pas aux mains des
russes puisqu'une partie de the blast
comme on appelle les régions sont
toujours contrôlés par ce soit celui de
louhansk ou celui de john yates toujours
contrôlée par l'armée ukrainienne qui a
renversé renforcer ses défenses l'étau
s'est même desserré autour de la grande
ville de kharkiv de près de la frontière
c'est la deuxième ville du pays de
l'ukraine tout près de la frontière
russe et l'étau s'est légèrement
desserré
et puis au dessin on le disait étonné
qu'ils aiment retrouver un semblant de
vie normale même si la capitale peut
être frappé d'un moment à l'autre par
par des missiles donc clairement pas de
grande victoire a apporté lors de cette
journée si importante symboliquement du
9 mai vous réagissez sur youtube sur
lefigaro.fr sur twitch je lis fabrice et
vous me l'aviez dit juste avant qu'on
prenne comprennent l'antenne je lis des
commentaires de personnes très
impressionné par ce hourra olivier jobin
qui le dit cheikh tidiane qui nous dit
ça fait froid dans le dos c'est
l'impression que vous l'avez vécu ça oui
c'est beau c'est une tradition
mais on n'a pas l'habitude de ce genre
de démonstration lors de notre 14
juillet à paris les troupes des fils
silencieusement entente m'enchante mais
ce ouvre à vraiment
galvanisé quand vous avez des plusieurs
dizaines de milliers
dom puisqu'on peut y avoir quelques
femmes dans le régiment mais présente
majorité d'hommes donc ces milliers
d'hommes qui cri sourd a parfaitement
synchronisé c'est évidement très
impressionnant je voudrais fabrice
maintenant qu'on voit que ce défilé a
démarré qu'on parle quand même de ce qui
se passe en ukraine parce que il y à
cette parade mais il ya aussi le
tragique en ukraine ferghana continue 60
morts dans 60 morts après un
bombardement d'une école dans une ville
de la région de lougansk ça ces
bombardements cette manière
d'impressionner vadimir poutine ne
compte pas l'abandonner bible non bien
sûr c'est
la tactique la manière de procéder de
l'armée russe dans la plupart des
conflits où elle a été
impliquée que ce soit évidemment la
tchétchénie faut pas oublier que
le règne de vladimir poutine en 1999
démarre avec une guerre en tchétchénie
certes une guerre civile puisque la
tchétchénie appartient appartenait
appartient à la russie la fédération de
russie enfin une guerre vraiment
sanglante il ya eu en 2008
l'intervention alors pour le coup et
intervention éclair en géorgie
là aussi avec quelques bombardements
dont indiscriminée et puis depuis le
début de cette guerre en ukraine depuis
deux mois et demi on sait qu'il y a les
installations civiles des hôpitaux des
écoles qui sont régulièrement visés il
ya souvent dans ce défilé militaire des
chefs d'état d'autres chefs d'état qui
sont habitées il n'y en a pas cette fois
et vous êtes journaliste au figaro
économie vous connaissez ce qui se fait
sur le plan des sanctions autour de
vladimir poutine est ce qu'il est isolé
vladimir poutine complètement alors si
on suit le narratif pour reprendre ce
terme à la mode occidentale on a
tendance à dire que oui vladimir poutine
est isolé parce que le g7 l'union
européenne
un certain nombre de pays effectivement
infliger des sanctions deux plus en plus
sévères contre le pays mais il faut pas
oublier qu'il ya plusieurs dizaines de
pays qui ont soit une attitude alors je
parle de pays émergents il ya aussi la
chine bien sûr qu'ils ont soit une
attitude de neutralité prudente
notamment dans lés neutralité void enfin
le terme est subtile oui en tout cas il
ya certains pays qui n'ont pas condamné
l' avance une invasion de l'ukraine et
puis qui se sont abstenus dans
différents votes aux nations unies
je vous rappelle que jean ping avait
assuré le numéro poutine de son amitié
sans limite juste quelques jours avant
le début de la guerre donc la russie
isolé du monde occidental ça c'est
absolument certain avec des sanctions
économiques qui vont lui coûter de plus
en plus cher qu'ils vont affaiblir
économiquement mais elle n'est pas
totalement coupé du monde avec les des
soutiens donc plus ou moins prudent de
pays comme la chine l'inde reste aussi
prudente lundi dans le premier ministre
était à paris tout récemment nokia pu
parler russie et ukraine avec emmanuel
macron et puis un certain nombre de pays
asiatiques de pays africains qui observe
encore une fois une neutralité soit
parce qu'ils ont des intérêts
commerciaux très important avec la
russie ou qu'ils estiment qu'ils n'ont
pas à s'aligner avec l'occident 9h33
nous sommes en direct 11h33 à moscou
lefigaro.fr youtube switch vous posez
vos questions on essaye d'y répondre
avec fabrice naudé l'envoi journaliste
au figaro économie et puis surtout
ancien correspondant pour le figaro à à
moscou pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
fabrice je voudrais faire deux points
qu'est-ce que se décider mais avant cela
qu'a dit vladimir poutine il s'est déjà
exprimée 9h15 9h26 était très court
qu'est ce qu'on peut en retenir un
discours cours pour je dirais galvaniser
la noce la nation
donner son propre récit de ce conflit en
disant qu'ils n'avaient d'autre choix
que d'intervenir en ukraine parce que la
russie était menacée par l'occident il a
même parlé de menaces contre contre
l'intégrité territoriale de la russie
donc justifié cette intervention
et il a fait un parallèle évidemment
soigneux entre la grande guerre
patriotique de quand on fait de la
victoire en 1945 et ce conflit actuel il
n'y a pas eu de grandes annonces comme
certains observateurs
spéculaient il ne peut pas annoncer non
plus de grandes victoires à deux
victoires bien sûr sur le terrain
ukrainien
il n'a pas renoncé non plus d'objectifs
de guerre vous savez il ya beaucoup de
spéculations sur finalement quels sont
les objectifs des députés important des
ministres de temps en temps lancent des
cailloux mais finalement donne des
objectifs parfois un peu contradictoire
donc rien n'est très clair est-ce que
vladimir poutine veut absolument
avoir la continuité territoriale jusqu'à
la moldavie avec la transnistrie sme
séparatiste pro russe est coincé entre
l'ukraine et la moldavie est ce qu ils
veulent simplement reconquérir
l'intégralité du dombass toujours est il
que hier il faut rappeler aussi le g7 le
pays du g7 donc etats unis canada japon
france allemagne grande-bretagne ont
publié un communiqué assez assez fort en
soutenant plus fortement que jamais
l'ukraine en soutenant en rappelant que
l'ukraine se battait pour son intégrité
territoriale et on avait l'impression
que pour la première fois explicitement
le g7 souhaitait clairement la victoire
de l'ukraine et son année le retour de
son intégrité territoriale intégrité
territoriale ça voudrait dire
reconquérir le dombass et la crimée et
ça on imagine que ça pourrait prendre
mais des années et des années bien sûr
d'autant qu'hier crimée et perdu depuis
2000 14 janvier 2014 donc la dîmière
poutine on peut résumer peut-être ce
qu'il a dit très précisément en disant
nous vaincrons en ukraine comme nous
avons vaincu en 1945 voilà pour résumer
finalement ce qu'a dit vladimir poutine
ce qui est assez vaste et pas forcément
très précis fabrice deuxième point je
voulais évoquer avec vous pour tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent ce défilé déjà
pourquoi le 9 mai est pas le 8 mai comme
en france je sais vous n'avez déjà dit
au début de ce live est demandé beaucoup
nous rejoint oui petit rappel c'est une
histoire de décalage horaire en fait la
reddition a été signé à berlin avec les
soviétiques le 8 mai 1945 à 23h01
précisément heure de berlin à moscou
milite et deux heures de plus il était
une heure du matin le 9 mai 1945 et
c'est donc cette date assez logiquement
que staline a retenu pour célébrer la
victoire et c'est ce que je disais c'est
que après dans le contexte de la guerre
froide il n'était sans doute pas
question que l'union soviétique d'un
côté et les alliés occidentaux de
l'autre célèbre cette victoire le même
jour sachant que la russie la union
soviétique à l'époque et la russie
toujours voulu insister sur le rôle
déterminant qu'elle a joué dans ce
conflit sur les pertes absolument
massive que l'union soviétique a subi un
plus de 20 millions de morts militaires
et civils c'est le pays qui a le plus
qui a payé du prix du sang le plus lourd
durant ce conflit mondial qui donne donc
ce caractère unique vous avez déjà vécu
ces défilés lorsque vous étiez
correspondra à moscou pour le figaro
racontez moi comment ça se passe c'est
très important pour les gens un ce
défilé pour les russes c'est le décider
mais c'est pas la fête nationale c'est
le défilé le plus important c'est la
journée la plus importante oui à
l'époque soviétique avait une autre fête
très importante c'était le 1er mai nous
ont aidés défilé populaire évidemment ça
a perdu de son importance au fil des
années depuis la fin de l'union
soviétique donc ce 9 mai reste
effectivement là le jour férié selon m
les sondages récents russe qui le
confirme c'est le jour férié le plus
important pour les russes donc ce
souvenir dit quand on dit que plus de 20
millions de russes sont morts enfin deux
soviétique donc c'est évidemment
beaucoup d'autres nationalités de
soviétiques sont morts pendant pendant
la guerre c'est un habitant sur 8 qui a
péri donc absolument toutes les familles
ont l'impression d'union soviétique ont
eu un parent
qui est décédé évidemment blessés et de
génération en génération même s'il ne
reste plus beaucoup de survivants de
cette époque 77 ans après sa marque est
extrêmement profondément mais plus
encore que nous c'est plus l'équivalent
de la saignée de notre première guerre
mondiale il ya eu plus de morts
proportionnellement à la population en
france durant le premier conflit mondial
qu'au cours du second est donc ça ça
vraiment marqués dans leur chair les
familles soviétique et donc russe au fil
des générations donc c'est un souvenir
très important je dire quel que soit le
contexte politique je lis que la
population à avoir le ruban de saint
georges en ruban orange et noir vont
m'expliquer ce que c'est j'imagine que
compliqué là bas vous avez vu se
revendent saint georges we say say say
say ce qui marque qui sa georges et
saint georges et est
associé à la victoire à la grande du
taur patriotique et on retrouve ces
bandes marron et et orange autour du
fameux z qui est devenu le symbole de
l'intervention russe en ukraine alors
vous avez il s'est un peu mystérieux
pourquoi ce z oui alors sur les leurs et
le z qui n'est pas dans l'alphabet
cyrillique mais depuis le 24 février les
blindés russes qui interviennent en
ukraine pour identifier avec ce z
vieille toutes sortes d'explications
aucune n'a été très convaincant mais
c'est devenu un vrai symbole il ya des
affiches à moscou avec le z qui était
pavoisé et avec ses fameuses couleurs
marron et orange de saint-georges et
tous les soldats arbore un ruban
pour rappeler saint-georges protecteur
de la russie mais pour l'instant on voit
ce défilé à pied des militaires on
aurait cru qu elle dans quelques
instants les défilés des véhicules des
avions avec notamment la patrouille
russe qui doit procéder en z oui et non
ça c'est extraordinaire ce symbole donc
il doit y avoir je crois à 8029 en
formation qui formeront z donc signe
actuellement explicite rappelant ce
celle qui symbolise les armées l'armée
russe qui intervient en ce moment même
en ukraine il devrait avoir un avion
aussi très spectaculaire on en parle
parce que ça fait à quelle heure il
passera oui mais alors il doit
normalement lancer suivant nos
informations ce défilé des véhicules et
donc de l'aviation parlez-moi de cet
avion l'iliouchine 80e' l80 n'a pas été
vu depuis 2010 cet avion et on l'a vu
dans le ciel de moscou lors des
répétitions qu'est ce que c'est que cet
avion par certains avions un gros
porteur avec une espèce d'excroissances
au dessus de son cockpit assez étonnant
il ressemble un avion civil et en fait
c'est le poste de commandement volant
qui permettrait au président de
commandes et même le feu nucléaire
depuis un avion en cas de conflit s'il
devait
quitter moscou pour une raison ou pour
une autre donc un poste de commandement
mobile volant très très spectaculaire et
donc le montrer aujourd'hui a évidemment
une signification très importante
alors que la lumière poutine ne cesse de
brandir la menace nucléaire pour pour
intimider l'occident on suivra ça dans
quelques instants je voudrais revenir
sur la la population ça c'est important
vous me disiez tout à l'heure qu'avant
seuls les militaires étaient sur le lieu
du défilé aujourd'hui c'est un peu
différent la population et là vous y
étiez à une époque où peut-être les
médias n'était pas encore aussi
contrôler mais est-ce que les gens qui
sont autour de cette place et qui voient
ce défilé militaire sont au courant de
ce qui se passe en ukraine alors ça
c'est toute la question de l'information
vous savez que la majorité de la
population russe s'informent par les
grandes chaînes de télévision qui opère
une propagande évidemment très très
contrôlée qui
occulte les pertes civiles en ukraine
qui occulte les pertes des soldats
russes en ukraine et parle d'opérations
spéciales de nazis à longueur de journée
et on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de réseaux
sociaux occidentaux ont été purement et
simplement interdit en russie après il
reste toujours des moyens de s'informer
mais ont depuis plusieurs semaines on a
souvent dans nos correspondants aussi
bien en ukraine que à la barre le est
notre correspondant à moscou on raconte
que parfois des familles qui sont
divisés entre russie ukraine parce qu'il
ya des liens familiaux très très
important très nombreux entre ukrainiens
et russes parfois des familles restées
qui sont en ukraine appel à leurs
parents à moscou ont désormais mais vous
avez vu ce qui se passe et les parents
restés à moscou abreuvés départ la
propagande ne croit même plus leurs
parents en les emmenant ses c'est faux
c'est vous qui êtes des menteurs je vois
bien ce qui se passe à la télé donc
c'est toujours très difficile de dire
quelle est la part de populations qui
sait vraiment ce qui se passe celle qui
ne veut pas savoir qui veut savoir qui
c'est là on est vraiment dans de la
spéculation il ré moyen de savoir mais
une grande partie de la population
adhère au récit officiel
ce défi des russes vous qui avez connu
peut-être la psychologie aarhus joly sur
sur lefigaro.fr charbon bleus qui ne
disent grand déploiement des forces
militaires russes les chinois font
pareil est ce qu'il ya une culture comme
ça militaire et russes sont très
attachés à leur armée plus qu'en france
que vous arrivez à le saisir ça alors le
la france accueille s'offre quand même
chaque année un défilé du 14 juillet
assez impressionnant qui avait
d'ailleurs impressionné donald ronald
trouverait absolument quand il avait été
invité les américains n'ont
effectivement par exemple pas de défilé
aussi important de jours dans l'année où
vraiment il ya une parade militaire où
toutes les armes
la marine l'aviation l'infanterie bien
sûr tous les régiments sont représentés
donc l'union soviétique -puis la russie-
ont conservé cette tradition la chine
aussi c'est effectivement une
démonstration de force qui selon les
années peut apporter des messages il ya
certaines années où les principes les
plus gros missiles nucléaires par
exemple ne défilait pas notre année où
ils défilent et là on s'attend à ce
qu'il soit présent c'est prévu au
programme oui notamment ce fameux
missiles rs-24 siar saint-leu hérité du
missile topol-m missile intercontinental
nucléaire 22 mètres de long qui peut
frapper minimum à 12000 km aux élus l'an
la vue décider déjà lors des répétitions
message oui oui oui parce que je faisais
certaines années ces missiles
transcontinentaux n'étaient pas déployés
là ils ne seront le message est très
clair on peut frapper n'importe qui
n'importe où n'importe quand 9h44 11h44
à moscou nous avons suivi le début de ce
défilé militaire et surtout la prise de
parole de vladimir poutine ça a été
court 9h15 plus tôt que d'habitude vous
nous disiez
fabrice au milieu de ce discours quand
deux mémoires alors je n'ai pas vérifié
mais il me semblait que le président
n'intervenait pas forcément il ne
faisait pas forcément un discours ou
alors juste très bref hommage à peine 1
minute de silence mais mais il me
semblait qu'il n'avait pas toujours un
discours pendant la parade mais là
encore une fois comme vous venez de lire
un discours assez court 10 minutes pad
annonces majeures si ce n'est un
parallèle bien entretenues entre le
conflit de de la seconde guerre mondiale
et celui qui a lieu actuellement en
ukraine je vois qu'on fasse un petit
point sur la première image qu'on avait
avec seriez choïgou le ministre de la
défense qui était présent et qui a passé
en revue les troupes avec se jouera à
chaque à chaque fois ils étaient sûrs
sur une voiture choïgou ça c'est assez
étonnant pas forcément étonnant mais en
tout cas marquant de le voir ici cette
part est enfin marquant en tout cas
c'est un signal
ce qui est normal après tout le must de
la défense doit être la sève mais on
n'était pas là pendant on l'a pas vue
pendant plusieurs semaines il avait un
peu disparu des écrans et donc dans ce
cas là je dis comme à l'époque
soviétique on tire des ans on s'attache
aux rumeurs on tire des conclusions sur
le peu d'informations qu'on a puisque
très peu de choses filtrent est donc
l'une toutes sortes de spéculations sur
la santé notamment du ministre de la
défense sergueï choïgou qui est vraiment
un très proche de vladimir poutine
poutine
infidèle séduit par exemple qu'on a pu
voir sur des photos il ya quelques
années ces fameuses parties de pêche de
venir poutine en sibérie torse nu
montrant ses pectoraux est souvent le
seul homme pour envoyer sur ces photos
qui l'accompagnait c'était sergueï
choïgou je vous propose qu'on écoute on
va à moscou 11 i cette parade militaire
que regardent passer la dmr poutine qui
s'est exprimé tout à l'heure on dîne
d'une dizaine de minutes maximum ça a
était assez court il n'a pas fait
d'annoncés très précises concernant la
guerre en ukraine il a seulement répété
ce parallèle ce parallèle entre la
grande guerre ait pu patriotique la
seconde guerre mondiale et 7 ce conflit
en ukraine on écoute ce qui se passe là
bas
[Musique]
voilà ce défilé des véhicules qui vient
de débuter alors ces véhicules justement
il y en a beaucoup qui sont
réquisitionnés en ukraine oui oui bien
sûr et on va voir la démonstration de
actuellement tout l'arsenal russe des
lance-roquettes lance missiles à plus
courte portrait est portée jusqu à pour
le disais tout à l'heure des missiles
transcontinentaux
roman tout tout l'arsenal et
et déployer là on voit des photos qui
sont les leurs expliqué mme rochet au
pare-brise de certains véhicules
ces photos elle serait plutôt des
vétérans des héros de la seconde guerre
mondiale est ce qu'il ya des héros enfin
des soldats tombés en ukraine
n'ai pas cette information mais alors on
précise parce que ces portraits a lieu
d'abord en effet chaque chaque 9 mai ce
défilé militaire et puis a lieu ensuite
le régiment immortel c'est un défilé
populaire où chaque russe porte marche
en portant un portrait de son d'un de
ses ancêtres morts pendant la grande
guerre patriotique la seconde guerre
mondiale c'est important ça ce défilé
populaire en comparaison à côté de celui
de ce défilé militaire bien sûr c'est
que pour montrer que toute la nation
russe et est uni derrière pour
commémorer cette victoire
appuyez peut-être la victoire que
vladimir poutine vient d'appeler de ses
voeux en ukraine défendez la patrie
qu'il irait jusqu'à la victoire en
ukraine donc évidemment rallier la
population c'est important parce qu'en
général je n'arrive pas bien à voir s'il
ya du public sur la place rouge mais
entre à l'époque où j'étais le public et
n'était pas le bienvenu sur la place
rouge on voit beaucoup de monde dans les
tribunes mais en général ce sont des
invités triés sur le volet mais des
responsables politiques évidemment
beaucoup de militaires des vétérans en
tout cas à l'époque où il en restait il
en reste deux de moins en moins 77 ans
après la victoire et le public en
général est reléguée dans les rues
adjacentes mais où cette année le défilé
va continuer à la barre lui et notre
correspondant à moscou nous nous parlait
d'un défilé long de 7 km est alors
c'était juste régression à sept
kilomètres de long avec donc ces
personnes ces russes un million de
personnes c'est à dire qui serait
attendu dans les led dans les rues de
moscou tout à fait possible sur certains
jours fériés c'est le jour férié le plus
important en général même quasiment tout
le temps il ne pleut pas ah oui alors
qu'ils ont volé - pourquoi par s'est
plaint c'est pas le hasard non notre
planète inventions se sont adressé
quelque chose qu'on raconte depuis
toujours que
les soviétiques déjà à l'époque
maîtriser la technologie dedans semences
et les nuages aliot dur d'argent pour
crever les nuages les faire pleuvoir
ailleurs que sur le centre de moscou et
on voit d'ailleurs le ciel s'est dégagé
depuis tout à l'heure j'étais un peu
plus nuageux l'on voit de belles
éclaircies bleus et ça c'est une
constante il fait normalement toujours
beau le 9 mai au dessus de la place
rouge ce défilé militaire toujours très
impressionnant à moscou mais en
parallèle de ce qui se passe en ukraine
est-ce que vladimir poutine peut encore
impressionné les occidentaux avec ce
genre de défilé lorsque nous nous
connaissons grâce aux journalistes aux
différents rapports au service secret
les difficultés russe en ukraine il ya
cette forme de schizophrénie entre eux
oui la puissance là à moscou et les
difficultés dans le donbass et ailleurs
en ukraine clairement le défilé
s'adresse avant tout au peuple russe
c'est pour montrer que effectivement
l'armée russe et est toujours très
puissante
montrer son arsenal c'est moins un
message adressé à l'occident enfin
peut-être aux opinions publiques
occidentales quand même parce que ce
défilé reste spectaculaire
mais évidemment c'est pas un message
adressé aux dirigeants occidentaux qui
ne va pas s'arrêter juste à cette
démonstration de force sur la place
rouge on a encore quelques minutes
ensemble fabrice voudrais vous poser une
question à propos de cette rumeur qu'on
a entendu est ce que disaient les
autorités ukrainiennes de la possibilité
des russes de faire un décidé à
marioupol de faire un geste et en
ukraine est-ce que ça c'est une
possibilité visiblement ça ne sera pas
le cas les russes ont démenti mais les
russes pourraient avoir la tentation de
décider en ukraine alors la tentation
était certainement forte
il y aurait pu avoir un défilé
relativement modeste de quelques troupes
reste qu'il ya toujours des combats
imaginez une image absolument
désastreuse pour la russie si le moindre
coup de feu étaient tirés sur un défilé
ce serait absolument désastreux
évidemment ce serait des images que la
télévision russe ne montrerai sans doute
pas alors je vous coupe parce que
regarder cette cette image avait alors
voilà ce missile tout particulier le rs
24 yaars ça c'est pas n'importe quoi
donc c'est ça ressemble c'est une quasi
fusée un cessna missile intercontinental
plus de 22 mètres de long un missile qui
est capable de frapper quasiment voilà
la planète entière puisque si vous il ya
douze mille kilomètres de rayon d'action
si vous partez d'extrême orient
sur rue ce pardon de du côté du détroit
de béring vous frapper l'amérique sans
problème vous partez de l'ouest vous
frappez absolument toute l'europe sans
problème donc là effectivement
démonstration de force symbolique ce
n'est pas la première fois que que la
russie que l'armée russe montre ses
missiles intercontinentaux parce que
dire c'est le sait le clou du spectacle
ce missile là qui est très
impressionnant en termes de volume 22
mètres de long
pardon nous en france on ne montre pas
sa note 14 juillet non non effectivement
les nos missiles intercontinentaux reste
sagement à l'abri dans leurs silos même
si c'est pour être juste une carcasse
pleinement vivre bien sur les routes
armes pour la démonstration mais en en
france effectivement ne montre pas nos
missiles intercontinentaux qui reste
dans nos sous marins
ou dans leurs silos dans leurs bases
aériennes voilà le missile rs-24 et
yaars que nous venons de voir défiler
l'autre point et puis on se quittera là
dessus vous pouvez réponse innée à vivre
ce défilé en stream sur lefigaro.fr et
on suivra ça particulièrement c'est cet
avion je dirais qu'on en parle une
dernière fois expliquez-moi cet avion
iliouchine 80 ça aussi c'est un message
fort de vladimir poutine oui c'est un
avion qu'on a pas vu souvent dans le
ciel donc un iliouchine aménagé qui
ressemble je dirais pour pour les non
initiés à hambourg un gros boeing qui a
d'ailleurs une protubérance au dessus du
cockpit qui fait un peu penser au boeing
747 et en fait c'est un poste de
commandement volant qui permettrait au
chef de l'état vladimir poutine de
commander le feu nucléaire depuis un
avion s'ils étaient obligés de quitter
moscou pour une raison quelconque et
montrer c'est pas deux pas du boulot une
seule fenêtre alors certains disent que
c'est un avion vieillissant un écueil
originalement
il serait pas utile que ça ce serait
juste de l'apparat je ne suis pas assez
qualifiés en matière de dépenses pour
vous répondre mais en tout cas le
montrer le faire voler au dessus de
moscou estime que
l'étape intervenir le président peut
déclencher le feu nucléaire à tout
moment où qu'ils soient fabrice nodé
langlois merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi
avec moi rapporter toutes vos précisions
sur ce défilé militaire on continue à le
suivre alors c'est en streaming sur
lefigaro.fr vous pouvez voir notamment
passé cet avion femme de liu xin 80 très
impressionnant et puis sur sur
lefigaro.fr sur figaro live vous pouvez
continuer à voir toutes les vidéos
notamment le discours de vladimir
poutine ce qu'il a dit ou ce qu'il n'a
pas dit à peu près ce que le dire comme
ça on s'attendait peut-être une
démonstration de force dans la parole de
la lumière tout cela n'a pas forcément
été le cas un parallèle constant entre
la seconde guerre mondiale et les
événements en ukraine mais pas beaucoup
plus merci de nous avoir suivis dans
quelques instants on se retrouve
également se faire un autre événement
autre thème avec régine évidemment les
obsèques de la chanteuse populaire
figaro live on suit tous les toutes les
actualités évidemment merci fabrice
naudé langlois à bientôt on se retrouve
tout de suite sur fear alive
[Musique]